no one town welcome to this video
Peregrine 64th my opponent I'm going for
Sicilian and see what he's doing I
wanted to play the night off in the last
game didn't get it it was Peregrine up
to and know a little something about
this Wow well it's usually not the idea
let's say night to be three days to go
h5 they all play 3 2 a.m.
it's a weird mix of system that white is
playing him really unsure what this
leads to you know if he is going to
Castle shoulder castle over here rather
long castles I guess but ok so am I
going Michael yahoo I think so what's
going on I can take can also take with
this actually put the bishop on f5 I'm
blundering before yeah right we can take
it I mean Stu is also attacked I think
that takes it to him anyway and I should
probably not given up the porn in the
first place
Kim and this is not so clear where the
queen is going i think you know you have
to go when yet to see one which is not
looking like the best possible square
yeah that of course in general is
generally the spring this is desirable
at form for white but i wonder if this
is maybe a tad loose at this particular
moment probably not objectively speaking
but it could be difficult to handle here
this a 3 e for stuff we play on the Play
on the long diagonal here so it doesn't
agree basically that it's somewhat
difficult and ignores it hmm I mean you
cannot move the beep are now or or am i
hallucinating I might be if you move the
beep on a play for a win win some
material so I thought you had to address
this somehow is
hmm with weird I got selected place
somehow I mean that was not an intended
sacrifice on before word
I'm sure what wats movers it's a little
bit awkward
through the scene I don't really see it
could move for it quite resigned that's
a bit strong but I don't see a move but
the engine gives but should be two with
a slight advantage for white they are of
course there you can do that resigning
was this was a bit weird as this one
adds okay make some Senate it gets out
of this prophylactically this can be
answered probably with with bishop t4
and here this is this is now not good at
all I mean I've gained a little bit here
with a and B point rated so the engine
also gives this is just have a pawn for
why itself it's still somewhat playable
but then it just blend it before in the
opening it was a weird mixture of
systems h3 is also the line that i play
with white so i have some some idea and
they all play this move now might be
three is very uncommon the idea is to
play g4 and 93 that that harmonizes well
with h3 might be threesome quite unusual
in this position and well i went h5 now
anyway it's the move that addresses
g-form i don't know where they have to
do that but this is the move plate after
night d to e 2 and 0 probably it's not
terribly bad you know what is mixing
like all kinds of systems you could
cancel short now still or long
everything everything is possible yeah
but now i'm what i'm doing is this is
certainly wrong I mean night takes
basically gives the pawn so that doesn't
really am inspire much confidence I mean
I can do this and play five but the
engine loves light with a 3m
yeah this is all these are common motifs
in this opening but I have a without
specific knowledge I have a hard time to
figure out if a certain idea is good or
not I kind of know what's know the ideas
for how to how to set maybe a five in
media this is what the engine gives but
again a three yeah maybe you can even
questioned be 50 yeah I could have taken
but this is actually worse according to
the comb it wants to play five so i may
be relatively speaking did a good job
there from the position quincy 71 would
that be equal C 3 i'd be 60 this isn't
it interesting this is a threat hmm well
that's the second somewhat believe that
this could be compensation the queenside
pawns they don't they don't to move that
quickly and this is a temple yeah that's
where I understand the engines 000 okay
not not didn't appreciate and here I
have some kind of play yeah a little bit
at this but he resigned I don't know he
has a very bad score against me maybe
I'm there's some kind of connection
there that he M sometimes you really
play we interview if you have a very bad
scoring and someone I know from
experience yes so lucky win there just
by resignation basically ok guys thanks
for watching